turning to the pandemic government
efforts to control the coronavirus in
canada have run into a wall of protests
from people opposed to the vaccine
mandates and other restrictions in the
capital city of ottawa thousands of
truckers and others have clogged the
city streets for more than 10 days
ottawa's mayor has now declared a state
of emergency the protests spread to
other cities and the protesters are
getting major support from the u.s
mualalangi has the details
[Music]
what started as a protest against u.s
and canadian rules requiring truckers to
be fully vaccinated to enter either
country
has erupted into a movement of thousands
against the canadian public health
system we don't need the government to
overreach to tell us what to do the
unvaccinated for two years have been
shamed
and thrown out of the bus
the protesters took to the streets for
the second week in a row with a convoy
of semi trucks blocking intersections
they brought downtown ottawa to a halt
disrupting businesses and flooding
police with calls about everything from
incessant honking to threats and assault
we're in the midst of a serious
emergency the most
serious emergency our city has ever
faced on sunday ottawa's mayor declared
a state of emergency asking for outside
help as local authorities say they are
outnumbered when the police chief
described being under siege
the protests have drawn praise from
former president donald trump and ottawa
police say the convoy is getting
significant logistical and financial
support from people in the united states
on friday gofundme shut down a
fundraiser for the so-called freedom
convoy which had garnered nearly 8
million u.s dollars in a statement the
company said it was done as a result of
multiple discussions with local law
enforcement and police reports of
violence and other unlawful activity
someone is going to get injured or
seriously killed if they don't
understand the severity of the situation
for cbs mornings i'm mola lenghi